good morning everyone
bonjour
thank you for joining us
mercedes are here today to provide an
operational update on the expected
arrival of a truck demonstration into
the downtown core of ottawa
foreign
my name is sebastian trombley and i will
be your moderator
before we begin a reminder to place your
michael's microphone on mute until i
invite you to ask your question
today we will be hearing remarks from
ottawa police service chief peter slowly
the chef du service de la police de tawa
peter slowly
followed by acting deputy chief trish
ferguson community policing the chef
ashwin pacquiao
general manager of the emergency and
protective services
available for questions from the media
following the statements we also have
oc
bill landry director traffic services
after we hear from the panelists we will
take questions from the media
we will now begin with remarks by chief
peter slowly
merci sebastian good morning
was built on the unseated algonquin
anishinabe territory the peoples of the
algonquin ashnavi nation have lived on
this territory for millennia
their culture and presence have nurtured
and continued to nurture this land
the ottawa police service in the city of
ottawa honors the peoples
and land of the algonquin anishinaabe
nation
the alva police service in the city of
ottawa honors all first nations inuit
and metis peoples
and their valuable past and present
contributions to this land
as you all know there is a major
demonstration taking place over the next
several days here in the nation's
capital
in fact demonstrators have already
started to arrive
and our officers have been managing a
series of small demonstrations in the
city core over the last
24 hours
so far they have been peaceful and
uneventful
the main demonstrations will commence
tomorrow
will continue through the weekend
and may continue into the following week
we know that there will be demonstrators
from across canada
including ottawa residents
the heart of canada's democracy
is our charter of rights
and freedoms the right to demonstrate
and to have our views heard peacefully
that said all rights and freedoms come
with responsibilities and limitations
public safety is paramount in all such
demonstrations
and will be in this demonstration
the safety of all the demonstrators
the safety of the city the community
the residents
the tourists
and the businesses
the safety of the police officers
along with our emergency services
and city of ottawa partners
the members of the ottawa police service
are duty-bound to protect the charter
and as such the ottawa police service
and our partners facilitate hundreds of
peaceful
lawful and safe demonstrations every
year regardless of the cause
the demonstrations this weekend will be
unique
fluid
risky and significant
these demonstrations are national in
scope
they're massive in scale
unfortunately they are polarizing
in nature
and they come almost two full years into
a highly stressful and tragic global
pandemic
there have been many concerns expressed
in the community
and many questions have been raised
about what we can expect over the next
several days
here is what we do know so far about the
core freedom convoy
demonstration the organizers have
advised us that this will be a peaceful
demonstration
they have confirmed that there will be a
large number of trucks
and participants
and that the main planned demonstrations
will take place on saturday
and sunday this weekend
with demonstrations of this scale there
are significant risks to be mitigated
but that we cannot fully eliminate
for instance
we have a major traffic plan to ensure
that emergency lanes are kept open
in the downtown core
but with hundreds of trucks
demonstrating in the downtown core for
days
we know that there will be major traffic
safety issues
there are unique variables associated
with this demonstration
some that we can influence
and some that will be beyond our ability
to fully control
for instance
we have been in constant communication
with the core freedom convoy organizers
still there are other parallel
demonstrators who we have not been able
to engage fully with
there are also social media actors
locally
nationally
and internationally
actors who may or may not actually come
to the city to
participate in the demonstrations but
who are nonetheless inciting hate
violence and in some cases criminality
to take place in our city
we still do not have a confirmed number
of trucks and demonstrators
we do not have an established end date
for the demonstrations
they could go through the weekend and
into next week
we do not know all the parallel
demonstrations that may occur
and or the lone wolf individuals who may
insert themselves into the mix
for various reasons
we do not know the full impact that a
demonstration of this size
scale and potential duration will have
on public safety or on public health
outcomes while we're in the latest phase
of the covet pandemic
based on what we do know so far i can
tell you that we have significantly
increased the level of local
provincial and national communication
and coordination
commensurate to the evolving nature of
the demonstration
this includes bringing in significantly
more police
national security
emergency services and city resources
starting today and increasing over the
weekend
ottawa residents and visitors can expect
to see a large police and emergency
services presence
in the downtown core
and on major highways and roads in and
around the city
as the demonstrators arrive in larger
numbers today major traffic delays and
congestion will occur
over the course of the weekend there
will be gridlock
gridlock in the core
and it will impact road usage
citywide we will do everything possible
to maintain emergency roots in the core
but we ask everyone not to visit or
travel in the downtown core if you do
not need to
for those of you living or working in
the downtown court we understand your
concerns
and we are working to lessen the impacts
on your lives
but there will be significant impacts
so please plan accordingly
try to do any shopping or errands today
anticipate that there will be little
ability for home delivery services in
the core
there may in fact be very limited
vehicle bicycle or even pedestrian
access to the corps for safety reasons
given that some areas may be very close
to demonstration sites and pose public
safety risks
the ottawa police service has resources
available to provide police services for
the rest of the city during the duration
of the demonstration period
that said we ask that you use your 911
communication services appropriately
that you do not make unnecessary police
service and emergency service demands
during this period that there may be
delays and in fact gaps in our services
depending on the impacts of the
demonstrations
over the past week we have been meeting
with our partners to develop an
operational plan to ensure that we have
the most current information and
intelligence from all available sources
this information intelligence informs
the spectrum of risks
threats and variables that we have to
plan for
we then make our plan and constantly
update those operational plans to secure
the most available and appropriate
resources
in our best attempt to mitigate if not
eliminate those threats
risks and variables
in an event such as this
with its ever evolving fluid and dynamic
nature
there will never be a perfect plan
and we do not have unlimited resources
as you will soon hear we have a variety
of well-developed and well-resourced
plans to try to adequately and
effectively address those known threats
risks and variables
we have plans for traffic disruption and
parking problems
we have plans for more serious issues
like damage to property
criminal acts or other violent behaviors
this includes the ability to gather
evidence along the traveled routes of
the demonstration
at the demonstration sites and online
in social media
let me be very clear
we are prepared to investigate
arrest if necessary
charge and prosecute
anyone who acts violently or breaks the
law in the demonstrations or in
association with the demonstrations
we have the capability and the
commitment
to pursue investigations and
prosecutions
well after the demonstrations have ended
this event has drawn a lot of attention
from mainstream media
elected officials and social media it
has the international community's
attention as well
this is an important issue for all
canadians
no matter where people live
or where they personally sit on the
spectrum of views in regards to the
issues being demonstrated about
that said it is irresponsible to inflame
this already volatile situation and in
some cases it may be illegal to express
hate or incite criminality and violence
in association demonstrations
we have seen in other jurisdictions
where such inflammatory behaviors have
led to people getting injured
killed
and or incarcerated
we are doing everything we can to ensure
that does not happen here
we are monitoring all intelligence and
coordinating with federal provincial and
local partners to ensure that we are
identifying those who can pose a threat
to the city over the coming days
we have evidently teams that will be
videotaping all aspects of the
demonstration
we'll be gathering evidence should there
be any acts of violence or unlawful
behavior
have intelligence assets and
investigators who will be working
throughout the entire event in the days
and weeks and months following the
demonstration should there be any
violence or acts of criminality
associated with the demonstration
we have consulted with the crown
attorney's office and we are prepared
both legally and operationally to
address any risks associated with the
demonstration
while we continue to facilitate people's
rights to protest under the charter of
rights in freedoms
we have also developed a plan to
facilitate the orderly and peaceful
departure
of the truck convoy from ottawa at the
end of the
demonstration we ask that everyone who
attends the demonstrations to be
respectful of each other
and to the area residents and businesses
to be respectful to the audible police
service officers and members
along with our police national security
emergency services and city of ottawa
partners
the ottawa police service and our
partners will do our very best to keep
all people healthy and safe
that said
we have a collective responsibility to
keep the community healthy and safe
we have to work together to enable
everyone demonstrators visitors
residents to get home safely for their
families
and their loved ones we will do
everything within our means to enable a
peaceful safe and healthy demonstration
this includes the timely departure of
all the demonstrators from the city
i will now hand it over to acting deputy
chief trish ferguson who leads the
audible police service response to the
upcoming demonstrations this weekend
deputy ferguson will provide a more
in-depth briefing on the planning and
operational framework for the
demonstrations thank you
thank you chief
good morning everyone and thank you all
for being here today
this briefing will provide you with the
most up-to-date information on the
preparation for this weekend's
demonstrations in ottawa
i realize there's a great deal of
interest in this event
from our community and in fact across
the country
the ottawa police service is the lead
agency and has overall command of this
event
over the last few days our team has been
finalizing operational plans in
anticipation of the demonstrations
of the manifestation
planning has involved coordination with
our policing and intelligence partners
at all levels of government and the
ottawa police would like to thank them
for their ongoing cooperation
information gathered continues to
indicate this will be a large and
significant event that is expected to
last throughout the weekend
we anticipate demonstrators will arrive
from several different directions in
large numbers with many heavy vehicles
and trucks
over the last few days we have received
feedback and questions from members of
our community
and today i will provide information
relating to the most common and pressing
issues for our residents so that
everyone understands and is aware of our
approach
we remain in regular contact with the
main with the many convoy organizers to
understand their plan and to ensure that
they have information relative to safe
driving routes and appropriate locations
to park in the city
we want to ensure demonstrators can
arrive and leave as efficiently and
safely as possible
the truck convoy will be directed to
these specific areas as they arrive in
ottawa
city staff have been making sure
appropriate signage is clearly visible
including no stopping or prohibited
parking zones
we have identified and will maintain
open lanes of traffic for our first
responders in emergencies throughout the
course of the demonstrations and the
weekend
communications
organization
manifestation
this work has been coordinated with our
city partners and i would extend our
thanks to our city office city of ottawa
colleagues for their ongoing support and
tireless efforts
our officers are here to protect the
rights of individuals to demonstrate
peacefully and in accordance with the
law we are also entrusted to intervene
when violence and laws are broken
and to restore peace
our focus will be to preserve the safety
of everyone involved
this includes ottawa residents
demonstrators and our police members
residents visitors and demonstrators
will see a very large president's police
presence over the weekend
we will have officers on foot in plain
clothes and using a variety of methods
to conduct evidence gathering and
observations of crowd
demonstrators and residents can expect
to see our members in different uniforms
with a variety of equipment on their
person and in different vehicles
[Music]
we have reassigned and deployed ottawa
police officers and we have called for
assistance from other police agencies to
ensure we have appropriate resources to
manage any eventuality
we have already consulted with crown
attorney
to ensure they are aware of our plans
and approach
while representatives from the convoy
have been cooperative thus far and have
informed us that their intentions are to
hold a peaceful and lawful
demonstrations
we are aware of other groups and
individuals who are likely to attend and
are not associated with the main
demonstration
and groups who do not share the same
peaceful goals
i would like to state that public safety
is paramount
there will be consequences for any
person engaging in or inciting criminal
or violent behavior
we are prepared to deal with any such
incidents including making arrests and
laying charges as appropriate
to our fellow citizens of ottawa we
appreciate that area businesses and
residents are concerned particularly
about information that they're seeing
online
we want to assure them that we are
taking every action possible to mitigate
the impacts of this event on daily life
in the city
but even with those efforts this will
have a significant impact on traffic
the stated goal of demonstrators is to
disrupt traffic to bring attention to
their cause
but it is simple if you do not need to
be downtown this weekend avoid the area
for those of you who live downtown
expect delays and major traffic
disruptions
make adjustments to your schedule
whether it be for groceries shopping
work appointments or deliveries
it will be more difficult to move around
especially by vehicle
we will work to keep you updated and we
ask that you rely on trusted sources
like our twitter feed at ottawa police
as well as the city of ottawa's feed at
ottawa underscore traffic
finally i'd like to call on everyone
involved in this weekend's events to be
respectful of one another and the
businesses and people that live here
this pandemic has been hard on all
canadians
it is important that we show compassion
for one another while exercising our
rights
that includes the local community the
demonstrators and police officers who
are working to keep everyone safe
as the police service for the national
capital our officers have kept the peace
at hundreds of demonstrations every year
these veteran officers know how to
ensure that everyone who attends goes
home safely i want to thank all the
officers who will be engaged this
weekend
this will be hard work in cold weather
and their professionalism and dedication
to this city and its citizens is
remarkable
[Music]
a security
mercy thank you
thank you acting deputy chief ferguson
we will now hear from kim ayotte
thank you chief slowly deputy ferguson
good morning everyone
as we all know a demonstration involving
a large convoy of trucks has come into
ottawa and will cause significant
traffic and transit delays and
disruptions this weekend
if possible residents should avoid
unnecessary travel through or into the
downtown core throughout the weekend
la fete
smith there is possibility that
disruptions may extend beyond sunday
there's a lot we don't know about this
weekend and how it will unfold but the
one thing i do know is that the city's
emergency plans are designed to be
flexible and adapt to different
situations
while ottawa police is the lead agency
in the preparations of this protest the
city has fully mobilized its dedicated
emergency operations center structure to
provide support and
coordinate communications
the city's traffic management traffic
incident management group which combines
the expertise of city police
services and ottawa in ottawa and
gatineau have been preparing for
different scenarios
the city is working with ottawa police
and developing a traffic and parking
management plans
and updates will be provided throughout
the weekend
on our regular channels
i want to assure ottawa residents that
emergency services throughout the city
will be deployed and focused on ensuring
that the safety of the public is
maintained and that dedicated lanes are
kept clear for emergency vehicles
if you at any time feel your safety is
threatened or if you need medical
emergency call 9-1-1
in the meantime the city is working with
ottawa police to keep the public
informed on city-wide traffic and
transit i encourage residents to follow
the city of ottawa on facebook and
twitter and stay up to date on services
on service changes that could affect you
the city of the city of ottawa will also
provide updates and maps on ottawa.ca
for traffic updates follow the city of
ottawa underscore traffic or use the
traffic monitoring app to check for
traffic congestion before you travel
oc transport buses and paratranspo will
also experience some delays
and detours may be required
to stay up to date on transit impacts
follow oc transpo twitter account
at
oc transpo.com or call 613-560-5000
thank you
thank you mr ayotte
i will now invite questions from each
agency alphabetically you may ask one
question with a follow-up
question
again a reminder to all participants to
keep their cameras off unless they are
speaking or asking questions
we'll now start with new zealand
fm
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
um
with the canadian press
yes thank you um i wanted to uh just
follow up on some comments from chief uh
spoolie um you said that uh you have
identified some other groups
and perhaps um individuals and whatnot
who are uh mixed in amongst the the core
organizers can you name or identify any
uh specific hate groups extremist groups
anything like that who have uh who have
been identified as being
or or who you fear are going to be
present
thank you very much for your question um
i'm not at this point able to
name any specific groups i can assure
you and the
public that we have full cooperation
from our national security agencies
including csis rcmp and their
international partners
and their assistance in conducting a
threat assessment from the beginning of
this
core demonstration all the way through
to the end of whatever combination of
demonstrations happened within the
nation's capital here
we have national provincial and local
intelligence working on this on a 24 7
basis
and even during the course of this
conference call we've had new
intelligence coming in in regards to
local threats
that will continue and we'll be as
prepared as possible to identify those
individuals or groups they may seek to
come here physically to cause harm to
the city to disrupt lawful
demonstrations or that may be inciting
hate and or criminal violence online
you have a follow-up plea
are you there
all right
sorry sorry about that i'd uh thought i
pushed it uh i'd also like to know more
about what you plan to do if the
protesters remain throughout the weekend
and into next week do you plan to let
them park on the streets for days um
what do you plan to do about that
thank you very much for the question
again
uh that's a very fluid part of the
entire operation
we have not yet received clarity from
the core demonstration
convoy as to what their end date and end
exit strategy will be but we are in
daily and constant communication with
those core organizers to make sure that
there's a full understanding of what
would be reasonable in terms of
an egress from the entire state of
affairs
we will certainly be extremely concerned
should there still be a large
set of demonstrations happening in the
city of ottawa in the downtown core as
we resume a normal work week on monday
there is increased traffic flow
pedestrian flow there are a number of
critical infrastructure
operations that need to happen from mass
transportation public education public
health
access to the roads will become even
more important than they are on the
weekends and so all those and other
factors will be at play in terms of our
negotiations and communication and
coordination with any demonstrators who
remain in the city past the weekend
based on the risk assessments we will
take an appropriate course of action we
are prepared and capable to remove
vehicles we are prepared and capable to
provide by-law enforcement how we
traffic active enforcement and criminal
enforcement should it be necessary
so far we've had good cooperation and
communication and coordination with the
core organizers of the main truck
demonstration and we'll do our best to
continue that throughout the entire
process as well with any other parallel
demonstrators but as i said earlier on
public safety is paramount the safety of
the demonstrators the safety of the city
the safety of our businesses
our residents
our officers emergency service providers
that will be at the top of the level top
of mind for every decision we make
around the nature of the demonstration
our response to it
and the requirement for people to end
thank you sir we will now go to joe tani
with cbc ottawa hi can you hear me
you sure can go ahead sir hey great uh
and just before i ask um i just want to
make sure i get an answer in both french
and english um
but uh yeah my my question is during
canada 150 dump trucks and snow plows
were deployed at intersections in the
parliamentary precinct to block access
by vehicles to the hill so i'm curious
why hasn't why wasn't that done this
time
thank you very much the question i'm
going to actually ask the acting deputy
chief chris ferguson to provide the
answer
thank you chief and thank you joe
um
so we there are a number of options that
we have
in order to uh to maintain safety and
and
access to routes uh in this case uh all
of those options were weighed and uh we
have determined that we would like to
keep one lane open and along
all of our major routes we will not be
shutting down any major arteries and if
when we do or if we do we will be
sharing that with the public
but our option on this one is to keep
our roots open so that we are able to
get emergency vehicles in and around the
downtown core as necessary
another disposition
[Music]
i'll get a response in in french and
english but i'm curious do the
protesters have
a demonstration permit
to my knowledge they do not at this
point
you know foreign
thank you jason we will now go to uh
jason white with city news ottawa jason
hi there uh so my uh first question uh
if i get the uh the deputy chief to
expand on a point i believe you were
making about truckers being directed to
uh specific routes or to specific areas
can you elaborate a bit on that um
specifically where are you directing the
truckers and and are there any specific
areas do you not want them to go for
example onto the grounds of parliament
hill or are there other areas where
you'd like the truckers and the
demonstrators to stay away from
thank you jason for the first part of
your question
we have obviously got people coming in
from east west and south
as well as north into the v into the
city proper
our traffic officers are managing that
and our police liaison teams have been
in communication with convoy cap team
captains as they are approaching the
city to let them know what the best uh
route for them to come in is we will be
rooting uh some trucks uh in from the
western route um and and the routes that
we have got uh selected so far uh
involve uh pinecrest exit we have the
kent exit we have uh to the east core um
or east of the core we have uh the
sir georgia10 parkway um and we will be
obviously monitoring uh traffic coming
over from the quebec side as well
uh so we will be
ensuring that we are getting roots
trucks in as efficiently and safely
obviously for some of the bigger
vehicles we want to
keep them out of
blocking intersections downtown so we
want to make sure that they're aware
of how what the best way the safest way
to
to make an ingress into the city is
um
i'm sorry the second part of your
question
yeah the second part of my question are
there areas where you don't want them to
go or you're asking them to stay away
from like the grounds of parliament
right thank you um the parliament
parliamentary precinct is uh looked
after by the
pps and so parliamentary protective
services we are working in conjunction
with them
to my understanding thus far
people are able to uh
find themselves on the grounds of
parliament
and we will work with them to make sure
that that is safe and
and that any any issues that arise there
we will be supporting but pps will be
the uh the decision maker in those ones
thank you
my follow-up question is about uh
washroom access downtown and and this is
for whoever feels best suited to respond
the mayor raised the possibility on our
station yesterday that he was not aware
of organizers arranging for portable
washrooms whereas usually that happens
in these large sorts of demonstrations
so has the city arranged for
porta-potties to be set up downtown
anywhere
have the organizers indicated they're
bringing them or what is the status
around that aspect
i'm not sure if uh mr ayotte has an
answer to that question um we have been
in a conversation with uh as i said
convoy captains uh and
apprising them of any of the um you know
facilities that would be potentially
available uh my understanding is that
there were porta potties were a
consideration uh in and around
parliament i'm not sure what the city of
ottawa has uh been involved with at this
point
yeah we're currently uh we're currently
assessing the need and quantity etc uh
we certainly we also have information
suggest that the organizers are uh
organized in that they have ordered uh
porta potties so now we're competing
with them uh with regards to access but
we are looking into that and and uh i
will hopefully have something
ready based on the number of people who
are showing up thank you
thank you jason uh we will now go to
xiao li with city news national
hi can everyone hear me all right
we can't
thank you um so my first question is of
course as the chief mentioned there are
certainly going to be people in the
convoy who are seeking to peacefully
protest as well as
other people who may be coming downtown
just to rubberneck despite advice not to
in the event that ottawa police needs to
clear the area or ask people to
peacefully disperse what sort of signals
will be given to the people who are
present so they're going to be able to
you know disperse peacefully
um thanks for the question charlie uh we
will you know as we normally do we have
equipment loud hailers
any types of
voice magnifiers if we need that
our officers will be in the crowd and
we'll be engaging with the crowd
and if it comes to a situation where we
are needing to evacuate a certain area
or disperse the crowd we will do so
first by you know obviously giving
people uh warnings and making requests
uh verbally through a variety of means
in order to
to achieve that
thanks very much for that answer and uh
as a follow-up i mean certainly january
6 in dc has been looming over lots of
people's thinking ahead of this convoy's
arrival i just wanted to ask if anyone
was prepared to speak a bit candidly
about
how present that risk
is in the thinking for ottawa police and
planning for this
thank you very much i'll take that
question i recognize that's been sewn
into the narrative of this
overall situation
while we are informed by events that
happen around the world and certainly
are to our neighbors south of the border
this is canada and this is the nation's
capital of ottawa
we have great faith and confidence in
canadians from coast to coast and in
this case we have canadians from coast
to coast
participating in the convoy and likely
coming on their own to some degree to
participate as individuals in and around
the demonstrations
with every confidence in the world that
the vast majority of people who are
choosing to come to the city or who live
in the city and choose to participate in
some form or the other within the
demonstrations will do so as canadians
do
lawfully peacefully and with respect to
everybody
that they will enact their charter of
rights
but also enact the responsibilities that
come with such freedoms
and they will work with the police
with the city of ottawa for the
emergency service providers to the
residents and the businesses to make
sure that their voices can be heard
their opinions can be shared
their frustrations can be aired and
they'll go home safely to their families
for those that choose to do otherwise
they can be assured that there will be a
commensurate response to any acts of
violence or criminality
any expressions of hate and intolerance
and any acts of disrespect
we're prepared as best as we possibly
can be for those that choose to come
here to do harm
to cause others to do harm
but this is canada and we truly believe
the vast majority of people involved in
any aspect of this
will do so peacefully and long
thanks very much for that
thank you sir we will now go to josh
pringle with ctv ottawa josh
uh thank you very much my question is
for chief slowly
we received several emails from
businesses concerned about safety of
their staff customers property leading
up to this weekend uh do you recommend
that businesses in the byward market
center town area close their doors this
weekend because of the protest
thank you very much an important
discussion that's been taking place over
the last several days
i can tell you uh over the last uh 72
hours our neighborhood response teams
our neighborhood resource teams
particularly the market team that has
been operating down
in the bywood market and in the main
commercial and retail area of the
downtown core of inactively meeting with
and speaking with and planning with
sharing information with the businesses
the residents the business improvement
associations the local councillor in
fact those meetings took place as as
late as this morning just prior to this
meeting we're sharing with them as much
information as we can so they can make
the most informed decisions possible
ultimately any private citizen and any
private business has to make their own
decisions as to whether or not to open
their business to have staff and
employees present
and to provide services goods or
services to the community our
responsibility is to give them the most
up-to-date information possible for them
to make those decisions
we will make sure that we are very aware
of the potential threats and risks that
could occur in and around their
residences their private residences and
their private businesses
and we'll do everything we can to keep
those people and their property as safe
as possible
so no recommendation just you'll provide
them the information and try to keep
them as safe as possible that's a
decision that every private individual
and private business owner has to make
on their own our responsibility is to
provide them with the most accurate
up-to-date information as well as the
services commensurate to the risk that
we committed
all right uh thank you josh we will now
go to david aiken with global national
news david
hi thank you very much everybody this
has been a very excellent briefing um
chief i wonder if i could come back to
just you mentioned
not really sure on the numbers and i
guess that's one of the things that's
making everybody a bit anxious um
kingston police services as you may be
aware on their twitter account did
release a bit of an accounting about the
number of tractors tractors trailers
personal vehicles um thunder bay opp i
spoke to them yesterday and they were
able to provide an accounting of the
group that came out of western canada
so by my count we got about 230
tractors and or tractor trailers and
about 725 cars that's just the convoy
from western canada and the one coming
out of toronto kingston
do you have some surely you've got some
information from tibet police about
what's coming from montreal maybe from
rcmp about what came out of the
maritimes do you have first of all do
those numbers sound roughly accurate
what i just gave you and what can you
add from what's coming from the east uh
so far as we're aware from other police
services
david thank you for your question um
i'll start if deputy ferguson has top up
i'll invite her to
complete the answer
um what you've described is accurate the
jurisdictions where the convoy is passed
through have been able to provide as of
that moment that day that our account of
vehicles and demonstrators that they're
able to ascertain
i think we also know that as this has
traveled from the west coast through the
prairies
now through ontario that the numbers
change the numbers swell well in
province and they shrink while they
cross the provincial border they swell
as they go through cities particularly
large regions and they drop off so
there's a steady state and then what i
would call an accordion effect as they
move through different jurisdictions
so until they arrive here we won't get
an accurate count that's the bottom line
we have estimations but we won't have an
accurate count until they actually
arrive in this jurisdiction you are
accurate we do have our quebec
provincial partners as well as our
police and and provincial partners in
the maritimes providing us with numbers
of persons and vehicles we're leaving
their jurisdiction and traveling towards
ottawa we expect that we're going to
have people arriving from the south the
east the west and the north and those
numbers will grow
as we go through the next 24 hours to 48
hours
the numbers you just gave me are
reasonably accurate with the briefings
that we've received overnight to this
morning in terms of what's coming
through the main
corridor up the 401 from windsor through
the gta into eastern ontario
with that i'll invite deputy ferguson to
top up any information with anything
more current that she has
thank you chief and thank you david for
the question um i think that's a fairly
accurate representation of what we've
been apprised of uh we are in touch with
uh our partners in the ontario
provincial police uh and getting updates
from them uh we have heard that there
could be uh from one to two hundred
vehicles coming from new brunswick and
what size and shape of vehicles we are
not um not aware of uh whether that is
all tractor trailers or a combination of
personal vehicles and and trucks
and we are also aware that there may be
a large volume of people moving across
from the quebec side over our gatineau
neighbors
so anywhere uh from you know 2 000
people but we have heard that these will
be on foot and we're expecting
pedestrians so um we are looking at any
number of a combination of uh of people
arriving on foot and in vehicles into
the city
thank you thank you very much um yeah i
mean i think
uh
i've seen lots of demonstrations on the
hill with you know ten thousand twenty
thousand people i guess it's the trucks
makes the thing a bit different um chief
one more question that uh you've
mentioned several times you talk about
the core organizers and i i wonder if
you can speak a little bit more about
who they are where they're coming from
how many we're trying to figure them out
too
i mentioned convoys coming from the west
from toronto elsewhere
um does each one have an organizer that
can you tell us
who these are and and how many there are
the core organized and where they're
from
david thank you i'll turn that question
over to deputy chief ferguson as she's
preparing the answer though i i will
just say i appreciate the focus has
remained on the trucks and the convoys
um
and again i i want to be clear to the
greatest extent we have received good
communication and cooperation from those
core organizers
um but as i talked about in my opening
comments and as debbie ferguson has
referred to
the risk factors extend beyond the core
demonstrators to those that have already
indicated um online and in other forums
that they're prepared to engage directly
or indirectly with the events that will
transpire over the next several days
here and some of them have been very
clear in inciting hate
encouraging acts of violence and
criminality
so
we have a good plan
well resourced focused on the core
element of a large vehicle convoy
entering into the downtown core of the
nation's capital and all of the risks
that come with that but we have the
asymmetric threats that
are attributed to individuals and groups
that are also parallel to this
demonstration engaging in online
activities and stating that they will
engage in in-person activities within
the city so it is a very complex
fast-moving and still very fluid
situation that we are managing to this
point i will invite deputy ferguson to
top up on your question
thank you sir um
we have seen the numbers grow and shrink
but we are currently eight separate
convoy captains who are we in we're in
communication with
thank you very much everyone um just
gonna check on a few outlets do we have
someone on from ctv national news kevin
gallagher or someone else
it's not like it
and do we have someone from cbc national
news
okay um then we will move on next to
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
for my first question i think it would
be for chief slowly i just wanted to
follow up on on a previous question by
one of my colleagues uh
and i'll ask the question a little
differently i know you said you don't
have any
recommendation for for businesses
downtown uh if they should open or not
so i'll ask the question differently
what would make your your your job
easier this weekend but would be easier
if uh if
a lesser number of businesses are opened
or or if if they're all open
uh thank you julian uh
uh i appreciate the reframing of the
question
from a from a policing and public safety
standpoint i'll be very blunt
the least amount of traffic vehicle
traffic bicycle traffic pedestrian
traffic other than our mass
transportation
in and around the downtown core will
facilitate to the greatest degree
possible a safe environment for
all involved
but i cannot dictate to individuals that
may have a medical appointment
who may need to seek or receive services
that are essential to their health and
safety
there are businesses that are essential
for
keeping this city moving even on a
weekend even on a short-term basis
so
it's irresponsible and quite frankly
impossible for us to dictate which of
those services can and should operate
it is responsible and it is possible for
us to provide the most up-to-date
information
in the most direct way that we can to
private citizens and business owners to
allow them to make the most informed
decisions we're encouraging people to do
what they can do today and over the next
24 hours to alleviate the need for them
to transact to travel
to receive services or seek services
outside of emergency services over the
course of the next several days but
people will have to make their own
informed decisions
that said should the threat environment
change substantially
should we have definitive information
that there are directed threats towards
any part of the city
any people in the city any businesses in
the city we will provide that
information and if necessary we'll make
very direct recommendations at that time
our threat intelligence does not provide
us with that level of risk
but if it changes we will change with it
as quickly and as effectively as
possible
thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
mercy we will now go to taylor blewett
with the ottawa citizen
thanks so much for this briefing um
first question would be for for the
police chief i believe would be best to
answer this um can you say is your main
concern about the the potential for
violence um
from those groups or individuals who
would be considered counter protesters
or those who've attached or associated
with the main convoy and and affiliated
demonstration activities
thank you for your question taylor um
again while there has been a lot
of very unfortunate and
at times very inflammatory discourse on
social media and other similar such
forms
we have yet to receive a direct threat
assessment
for any group
that we can reasonably anticipate is
coming to the nation capital
we cannot however ignore the rhetoric
we cannot ignore the direct hate
language and threats
we cannot ignore the direct attempts to
incite violence and criminality
in and around the demonstration
should the situation change and we can
identify individuals
or groups
where there is clear enough information
that they intend to act in a criminal or
violent manner there are a range of
options for us to interdict those
individuals as early as possible prior
to them being able to cause
significant if any harm
i mentioned in my opening briefing we
are
prepared with intelligence assets
investigators
the support of many other police
services
from across the province our partners
with the rcmp circadia quebec
ontario provincial police
to interdict where necessary
individuals or groups
we can determine are planning to or
imminently about to commit acts of
violence or criminality
our liaison with the crown attorney's
office
will allow for
coordination around
investigations and subsequent
prosecutions
commensurate to the acts of individuals
there will be consequences for those
individuals
right now
what we expect and what we've been told
by the main organizers
is a peaceful and cooperative
demonstration over several days in the
nation's capital
there are risks associated just to that
we've talked about that in terms of
traffic congestion the potential for
a range of
problems that come with a congested area
a downtown core
and we're doing our best to mitigate
that but we are prepared to deal with
any individuals or groups
that come here to cause harm
or to commit crimes
or in the course of the demonstration
come into friction with each other
and spontaneously
crime or violence happens
that's why again we ask everyone to come
here with a true intention
to demonstrate
and to use their charter rights and
freedoms to the fullest extent while
being responsible and respectful in
every way to everybody
thank you
and does a follow-up
unrelated but have police force members
or city staff received any directives
from their management or leadership
about personal participation in this
convoy demonstrations or related
activities
thank you for your question i i won't
speak for kim ayotte i'll leave him to
speak for the city of ottawa
as with every
demonstration that we have and quite
frankly our 24 7 responsibilities to
keep a million people in this city
safe through their police services
our responsibilities to our oath of
office and not to our personal views
our values and our policy structure are
always in place regardless of whether
there's a demonstration or it's just
day-to-day operations
my expectation of chief of police of the
ivo police service
is that every member of this service
will adhere to their oath of office our
core values and their policies
if there are any breaches of those areas
there will be commensurate responses and
there will be consequences associated to
it specifically when we have a large
demonstration like this within our
operational plan and our briefings we
remind our officers and our members of
their oath of office and their
responsibilities of the standards of
dress and deportment
the requirements for effective
professional communication so that there
is no misunderstanding and no forgetting
of the standards expected of the audible
police service and its members and that
includes me as chief of police
i'll leave it to kim if he would like to
speak on behalf of the city of ottawa
well chief that was very well said and
it applies to all city employees as well
we have a very strict code of conduct
and we would expect everyone to to
follow that code and to
you know
act accordingly and uh any breaches of
that uh will be investigated and uh
we'll look into the consequences as well
but that
very much along the lines of what you
just said chief
um
[Music]
um
foreign
i'll
take first step with that thank you for
your question
um
first of all as a reference and as
deputy ferguson has talked about
the planning for this event
started a week ago
uh it has involved uh at every step of
the way and will continue all the way
uh coordination information sharing
intelligence sharing
threat risk assessment sharing between
local provincial national
agencies including our national security
agencies and those agencies that have
direct responsibility for the security
security of parliament
parliamentarians from all parties and
significant public officials
i will tell you with great confidence
that we have received briefings i have
had direct briefings between myself and
rcmp commissioner brenda lucky in the
last 24 hours
i've had direct briefings with between
myself and opp commissioner tom karik
on the status of
threat assessments relating to
provincial and federal government and
officials elected officials public
officials
i think it is also relevant that over
the course of this pandemic and in
recent years unfortunately
we have seen increasing
threats and targets towards elected
officials and public officials
again unfortunately and it is an
important
point to make
leaders
who are trying to advance public safety
public health outcomes and our
government
have been targeted here in this city we
have had
uh municipal councillors
uh provincial members of provincial
parliament and members of parliament
uh directly uh threatened
um
we've had our own mayor the victim of
hate crimes and hate incidents
this is not canadian
more importantly this is not lawful and
as i said
the ottawa police service and our
policing partners national security
partners
will take
very strong immediate and prolonged
steps
to investigate arrest if necessary
charge and prosecute anybody who commits
acts of criminality
acts of violence or incites hate that
results in criminality or violence
pascal versions
um
[Music]
um
um
see we will now go to alex balangal with
the toronto star
hi thanks very much so i was trying to
change my name to put toronto startup so
thank you for uh for identifying me
appreciate it
um
i just uh for chief slowly on the um you
mentioned the parallel groups i'm
wondering if you can get more specific
about which groups you're referring to
if you can get that specific we
obviously have the trucker convoys the
eight captains you guys mentioned but
these parallel groups that you've talked
about that you're concerned with
who are they what are we talking about
there
i appreciate the question and i know it
was asked before
at this point we're not in a position to
to name groups
the intelligence is ongoing
that will not cease until
the complete end of the demonstration
and even after that there will still be
follow-up potential fault investigations
or issues that require intelligence
operations
as of right now the concern is the
totality of the circumstances that we're
facing
we have a core set of demonstrations and
a clear and consistent indication clear
and consistent statements by individuals
who claim to be parts of other groups
or who actually claim to be just acting
on an individual basis who say that they
will become involved directly or
indirectly in the set of demonstrations
happening over the next several days
and a small portion of those individuals
are attributing their actions
to
direct criminality direct acts of
violence
or inciting others
to commit direct criminality and direct
active violence in the city and those
risks cannot be ignored will not be
ignored and are being addressed to the
greatest degree possible but the ability
for us to name specific individuals or
groups at this point that is not an
opportunity for us right now
okay thanks for that and just you
mentioned um i'm not sure if you can get
into more specifics than what you said
but when talking about the elected
officials and the doxxing warning that
that went out last night to mps
um you'd spoken with commissioner lucky
and the opp about
the thrust threat assessments against
officials
can you share what the assessment is at
this point like is is there a risk to
elected individual or elected officials
at this point what what is the threat
assessment for those people right now
thank you
the nature of the threats that we have
seen
in the last 18 to 24 months
are similar to the nature of the threats
that we've seen in the last 18 to 24
hours
the reference doxing i think that's
probably the predominant
uh methodology of delivering threatening
or hate-filled
activities towards elected officials
public officials and and private
citizens business owners
um uh doxing is one form of it uh a very
pernicious and debilitating form
um
but statements uh again that incite
criminal behavior that incite
hate
uh to individuals we've seen
misogynistic hate racist hate
homophobic hate
we've seen threatens threat threats of
assault and behavior mischief
some of those have translated into
actual incidents over the last 24 months
that members of the ottawa police
service
have joined with our national security
partners in investigating and following
up and we've laid charges in some cases
we're prepared to do so if anything like
that transpires over the next 48 to 72
hours
the lead role for protecting
parliamentarians is with the rcmp and
the lead role for protecting parliament
hill and its and its related buildings
are with parliamentary protective
services they are fully engaged and
incorporated within the operational plan
and within the command center operations
and so anything that should occur in and
around the demonstrations in the next
several days that relates to the
security of the parliament buildings
the parliamentarians or public officials
will be dealt with in a coordinated and
immediate manner
but this is a problem that we're seeing
in broader society where elected
officials and public officials are the
subject of hate the subject of the
incitement of crimes against them and
the actual victimization as i said
before it's illegal
and i believe it's
incredibly uncanadian
we can and should do better as a society
but for those that fall below that
standard there will be a response in
this jurisdiction and other
jurisdictions
thank you this concludes today's media
availability so that concludes the point
the press also thank you everyone for
making yourselves available mercia tutus
[Music]
you